well there's obviously different kinds
of love and the Greeks had all different
terms for it and in the strongest
relationships we have those kinds of
love you know you know they are
simultaneously the ebb and flow
sometimes they're all there at the same
time you know eros & agape which is the
more sort of love of mankind you know
selfless kind of love and philia which
is kind of a deeper sort of non-sexual
affinity and you know so I don't really
have any there's no rules that I've
learned about the evidence love those
experiences I mean we don't we know that
we seem to learn some things from
relationships that don't always seem to
work the next time around I mean you try
to avoid patterns and you learn about
ourselves you know over time I married
my mom again all right you know I made
that mistake again strange but it's you
know you hopefully learn along the way
what is useful what isn't useful and
then the next time someone comes around
you forget it all so I don't know you
know there's a there's an understanding
of different kinds of connection and as
long as you don't mistake one for the
other I think that's useful you know
there's a there's an infatuation with
someone there's there's the depth of a
long relationship or friendship or love
relationship that feels very different
and in the end is perhaps the most
valuable and there's uh there's a kind
of hard-won wisdom that maybe comes out
of all those all those relationships
which ultimately you know are trying to
help you understand
what it means to love yourself and to to
love the time alone at the end of Hedvig
this fragmented face that kind of comes
together as she seems to find a certain
wholeness in herself internally rather
than by defining herself as a half and
seeking another half you know when you
are defining when you're thinking of a
lover or someone who completes you it
almost disrespects them and yourself by
calling both of you incomplete or you're
nothing but something to you know fill
the wound you know to cover to cover the
you know it's something complimentary
rather than respecting someone as a
whole and that might not always be
useful even though it's very powerful
for people so it you know it's it's an
ongoing it's an ongoing understanding in
question and I hope there's a what's
nice about the about hedvig that it
doesn't define anything too strongly and
it seems to have different
interpretations across cultures you know
being in different countries and
people's reaction to the myth and to
advocates really interesting it feels
international